[blade drawn]
This is the weapons tests.
There will be a strength
test, a sharpness test.
And up first, the kill test.
Doug?
Jason, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[dramatic music]
[thwack]
[slicing sound]
[exhales heavily]
[dramatic music]
That was the coolest
thing I've ever seen.
All right, Jason.
This weapon is fast.
It's maneuverable.
Your tip here is sharp enough
to penetrate and lacerate
on the way out.
The only one issue here is
that it did pick up a bend.
But, overall, your
weapon, sir, will kill.
Thank you.
All right, Spicy
Mike, you ready?
[laughs] Let's do it.
Let's do this.
[dramatic music]
[thwack]
[heavy metal music]
[slicing sound]
[thwack]
[heavy metal music]
[slicing sound]
[laughs]
[dramatic music]
[thud]
- [laughs]
That's awesome!
[dramatic music]
Did I do that?
Spicy Mike, your
[inaudible],, it's
wide enough to break bone as
I was thrusting into the chest
cavity.
It's a light, fast weapon.
And, most importantly,
it will kill.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen.
Now it's my turn,
the strength test.
Now, remember, this test is
not about what your blades can
do to the target, but what these
targets can do to your blades.
All right, Jason, you're up.
You read?
Yes, sir.
OK.
[dramatic music]
[heavy metal music]
[clattering]
[thwack]
[heavy metal music]
[dramatic music]
All right, Jason.
Well, this has got some
serious heft to it.
That bend didn't change any.
What I do like to
see is the fact
that your edges are just fine.
It's a strong weapon.
Definitely did what
it's supposed to do.
So good job.
Thank you.
All right, Michael.
You ready?
Yeah.
[dramatic music]
[clattering]
[heavy metal music]
[thwack]
Awesome.
All right.
Well, your weapon is
still in one piece.
It's still sharp.
You didn't lose any
of that blade at all.
It's well done.
A good weapon.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, this
is the sharpest test,
the banner raise.
Jason, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[heavy metal music]
[fabric cutting]
That was neat.
Your crescent
blade is very sharp.
It cut cleanly through the rope.
One and done.
The edges of your
flamberge are sharp.
The tip easily pierced it
and sliced all the way down.
Overall, sir, your
weapon will cut.
All right, Michael, your turn.
You ready?
Let's do it.
Let's do this.
[heavy metal music]
[fabric cutting]
All right, Mike, on
your crescent blade,
the edge is sharp.
Your flamberge over
here, the point is sharp,
the edges are sharp.
It was very easy to slide down.
Overall, sir, your
weapon will cut.
Jason, Michael,
you guys brought us
exactly what we asked for.
But, unfortunately, there can
only be one "Forged in Fire"
champion.
Spicy Mike, congratulations.
You are our new "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and that is a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, man.
Oh, this is like the
proudest moment my entire life.
Well, congratulations, man.
You did some fantastic work.
Please present your
blade to our judges.
I won!
I'm this crazy guy
with a weird nickname
from the middle of nowhere.
But I did it!